wieso gehen sie nicht nochmals italien
ja immer zu reinigen ist keine keine für
mich chance mehr zu überleben
das ist konflikt mit dem gesetzlich habe
keine einfache recht zum sozial ist wir
bekommen
brakel nach etwas medikamente weiter
zunehmen für meine gesund das problem an
ich bin gesund und aussagen ist seine
gesundheit dies in ordnung kommt nicht
mehr zurück in deine krankheit ich
sofort verlassen
die schweizer gehen nach barcelona
valencia hat krebs und noch einige
probleme mehr
wie bewahrt man haltung in einer
ausweglosen situation
darum geht es in diesem film
[Musik]
wir befinden uns in aarwangen im kanton
bern
mitten im dorf und doch ganz für sich
allein steht das durchgangszentrum das
vorübergehende zuhause von 200 menschen
aus über 20 nationen für gut 30 von
ihnen ist der traum von einer zukunft in
der schweiz geplatzt
ihr asylgesuch wurde abgelehnt aber sie
können aus verschiedenen gründen nicht
ausgeschafft werden sowie biel and your
fass mazedonien der wegen seiner
krankheit bleiben darf aber nur noch
nothilfe erhält das heißt auch franken
pro tag also 56 franken pro woche
gleichwohl bleibt der schweiz fans man
sagt wenn man dem schweizer ein wenig
zeit lässt und mit ihm warm wird dann
wird er weich und schmilzt wie
schokolade
schweiz hat mir viel geholfen
mit der medizinische besorgen mit der
humanitären besorgen mit alles ich habe
eine dach bekommen von dem migration und
die haben eine sozialhilfe wirklichen er
wöchentlich 56 tragen das ist reich das
ist gleichsam ja klar das ist eine rein
geld die schweizer muss zum arbeiten für
diese ganz und selber besonnen
wer sie landen oder illegal combinale
gratis von imagination eine humanitäre
gratis hilfe
auch ibrahims asylgesuch wurde abgelehnt
auch er musste gehen aber auch er bleibt
manchmal frage ich mich wieso ich in
marokko geboren wurde
jeden tag denke ich wenn ich nicht in
marokko sondern in europa zur welt
gekommen wäre hätte ich wohl eine chance
im leben
ibrahim sagt der seit 32 und 44 jahren
in die schweiz gekommen hätte längst
wieder ausreisen müssen aber marokko
nimmt nur landsleute zurück welche die
schweiz freiwillig verlassen
ibrahim geht jedoch nicht freiwillig
darum kann in die schweiz nicht auch
schaffen
[Musik]
hier sind familien untergebracht frauen
die alleine mit ihren kindern unterwegs
sind und dort ist die küche kommen sie
nur hier sehen sie es die küche ist ab 7
uhr morgens offen und wir nachts um halb
zwölf geschlossen
das ist ein freund von mir er redet sehr
gut englisch ein sehr netter mann aus
dem sudan
im moment wird er gerade gut
natürlich gibt es hier manchmal probleme
so viele verschiedene religionen und
charaktere
er hat es für jeden einen schrank in dem
er seine sachen einschließen kann
ibrahim hat sich mit dem kanal hassan
angefreundet der ebenfalls nothilfe
bezieht und trotzdem bleibt hier im
einstigen heim für schwererziehbare
knaben das zu einem durchgangszentrum
für asylsuchende umfunktioniert wurde
wieso gehen die beiden nicht einfach
wieder nach hause
frage ich mich ist das leben hier besser
als in ihrem heimatland
sagen wir es so
hier habe ich meine freiheit man lässt
mich enorm
ich habe zu essen und ein band in ghana
muss ich leiden bevor ich etwas zu essen
bekommen hier ist das nicht zu hier gibt
man mehr das nötigste
ich muss nicht leiden um etwas in den
magen zu bekommen das ist der
unterschied
ja ich fühle mich hier auch sicher hier
habe ich nicht viel aber es ist immer
noch besser als in einer hand
das durchgangszentrum aarwangen
unter dem strich offenbar ein
fortschritt für diese menschen trotz
allem was haben sie für eine perspektive
in einem land in dem sie sich illegal
aufhalten
ich weiß es auch nicht
das ist sehr hart ich hoffe einfach
ich hoffe dass die schweiz vielleicht
eines tages die regeln für die
einwanderung ändert während ibrahim
weiter versucht ein licht am ende des
tunnels zu sehen scheint haus samt die
zuversicht langsam abhanden zu kommen
mein anwalt hat rekurs eingelegt gegen
den negativen asylentscheid aber ich
hatte keine chance
und wenn ich keine chance habe es ist
wohl besser wenn ich die schweiz
verlassen
ich kann nicht einfach illegal irrt
lagen sie können schon als illegaler
darf ich nicht mal das durchgangszentrum
verlassen wenn ich rausgehe und von der
polizei kontrolliert werde bekomme ich
probleme
das will ich nicht
[Musik]
darum denke ich dass es besser ist wenn
ich gehe natürlich ist es nicht gut für
mich nach ghana zurück zu geben
aber was soll ich machen ich weiß keine
lösung die einzige lösung ist wenn ich
die schweiz verlassen
das ist besser für mich
[Musik]
guten tag
ja ich schaue in witzin sie sagen so
danke das durchgangszentrum aarwangen
wird von der heilsarmee betrieben
sie startet jeden neuankömmling gratis
mit einer garnitur von kleidern aus die
gespendet wurden damit nicht gehaftet
wird kosten zusätzliche stücke und ich
wollte so spielfilm eines essengeld ich
muss von ihr einkaufen
das ist billig und was neu das ist sehr
gut
das kostet nicht vielleicht eine frank
und schuhe auch schöne schuhe einer
frank das für mich nun mal die andere
länder gibt nicht so etwas wie hier die
anderen länder vielleicht gibt aber muss
mehr geld zu kaufen
aber hier ist dass alle militärischen
wie gratis bekommen
für unzählige amerika sie und wer muss
das akzeptieren muss das kauf hallo mein
kopf ist fertig dieses schöne sache was
kosten diese jacke bitte dass wir anfang
einfach danke auch ag
er sei helios chinas auf dieser mann
sein asylgesuch wurde ebenfalls
abgelehnt
er müsste auch so gehen bleibt aber seit
nunmehr elf jahren folgen lassen hier
vor gericht zusammen mit einem afghanen
versuchte das durchgangszentrum sauber
zu halten
eine sisyphusarbeit also diese nutzung
fällt aber diese andere sachen nasa und
die eltern nicht die eltern der kinder
ihre kinder diese fast erneuern hier die
vorstellt und da immer hier sie muss ich
machen
diese autofahrer oder straße lassen
jeden tag muss putzen harry stört sich
allerdings nicht nur am grassierenden
littering sondern auch am nächtlichen
lärm emissionen
ibrahim und hassan haben sich im
durchgangszentrum einen ruf als maler
erarbeitet sie gelten als motiviert
zuverlässig und genau darum dürfen sie
ab und zu ein zimmer streichen
in diesem fall eine küche es tut mir gut
etwas zu tun zu haben
wenn ich jede woche etwas machen darf
wird es mir besser
ich weiß wie man das macht ich habe ein
marokko auch so gearbeitet
sie können sich noch so viel mühe geben
ihr engagement ändert nichts an der
ausweglosigkeit ihrer situation aber die
zeit geht ein bisschen schneller vorbei
immerhin ich übersetze auch für die
leute hier und ich schneide ihnen die
haare
ich bin ein professionelles café du
stimmst mir doch zu hassen oder ich habe
hier drei jobs nothilfebezüger haben sie
auch franken pro tag zu gut mit solchen
arbeiten können sie sich etwas
dazuverdienen 30 franken pro woche in
form von essensgutscheinen für die
migros
[Musik]
solche essensgutscheine bekommt auch
harry für sein tägliches putzen rund ums
zentrum
die meisten dieser gutscheine sparte
jedoch für schlechtere zeiten
es sind sie im chinesisch ja was in kauf
dieser fisch fisch aber eine gute note
weil sein vater politisch aktiv gewesen
sei sei die ganze familie in china
verfolgt worden sagt kniep die schweizer
behörden glaubten das nicht und leben
sein asylgesuch ab da ist eine papiere
verschwinden ließ und sich weigert sich
gegenüber seiner botschaft zu
identifizieren stellt in china kein
ersatz reisedokument aus und ohne
reisedokumente kann er nicht ausreisen
jetzt brachen arbeit zahlen ausweist
diese aller bei normalen leben ist so
weiterleben
herr lee floh mit seiner frau aus china
kurz nach der ankunft in der schweiz
gebracht sich meine tochter die
inzwischen zehn jahre alt ist und den
erfahrungen zur schule geht ja auch die
kinder von papierlosen haben ein recht
auf bildung herr lee hat dieses recht
indes nicht keine bleibeperspektive
bedeutet keine deutschkurse auch so
lernte er allein
ich freue mich sie können nun nehmen die
sowjetzone termin erhält kannst du so
gut durch das ist ja total toll es ist
schon spät leider muss ich gehe
doch recht gut da habe ich schon
gewartet ich danke für das ist jetzt
nicht so viel ich muss erzählt und ich
mache noch eine kuh und das könnte
helfen gut danke für gott das ist ja
habe ich schon gelesen wir ja jetzt
eigentlich katholisch und möchte es auch
bleiben trotzdem empfängt der woche für
woche erneut einen prediger der zeugen
jehovas
zusammen versuchen die beiden gottes
wege zu ergründen
kapitel 3
wie kann uns den hebel bei persönlichen
problemen helen ist die liebe zeigt wie
gut sein wird oder dein wille soll auf
der erde geschickt sondern andere
besetzungen gelesen hatte dass sein
reich komme sein wille geschehe wie im
himmel zu auch in erlangen
das jahr auf krebs hat wurde nach
dreimonatiger ausschaffungshaft im
regionalgefängnis burgdorf festgestellt
nach der diagnose wurde die ausschaffung
ausgesetzt bis heute gefängnisdirektor
marcel zeigt das übliche prozedere wenn
leute wie er oft tatsächlich
ausgeschafft werden
mit dem weg ist so viel ist das letzte
mal doch noch und die zahlen je nach
höhe mit eines vergrößere modus ist eine
person nicht die weiße haus mit die hat
auch bereits auf einer packung hat zum
teil bezahlen und man auch hat er
zusammen mit der polizei könne diese
kohle waren damit bereits spanisch und
da ist eine doline das passiert
allerdings immer seltener die plätze für
ausschaffungshaft wurden im
regionalgefängnis burgdorf in den
vergangenen jahren von 32 auf 7
reduziert
die nachfrage sei schlicht eingebrochen
heißt es hier
[Musik]
der kantonale migrationsdienst bestätigt
dass claudia ransberger ist
bereichsleiterin asyl und rückkehr den
einbruch der nachfrage ihrerseits
erklärt sich so bleibt aber in
strategisch sind unter anderem reduziert
worden
aufgrund von 260 vor der person wo jetzt
die entwicklung zeigt dass mir immer
weniger negativen asylentscheid über
räume zum vollzug und ist ein grund
haben wir weniger bedarf verhaftet mit
anderen worten der fokus liegt nicht
mehr auf ausschaffungen sondern darauf
unterkünfte für die neuankömmlinge zu
organisieren die bleiben auch für
diejenigen die eigentlich gar nicht
bleiben dürften die hier keine
perspektive haben aber offenbar auch
nirgendwo anders kommen sie zeigt uns
ein zimmer in afghanistan sei es besser
gewesen als hier findet dieser mann
seine familie darf bleiben
trotzdem ist er mit der gesamtsituation
offenbar eher unzufrieden
das hauptproblem ist dass in diesem jahr
zwei familien mit verschiedenen
muttersprachen zusammenleben müssen
er sagt es brauche jetzt endlich eine
lösung
er sagt eine andere familie sei schon
nach zwei monaten weiter transferiert
worden
er wartet jetzt schon seit vier monaten
er versteht nicht wieso er nicht
transferiert wird
das ist keine lösung für diese menschen
hier sie wünschen sich dass die schweiz
bald eine andere lösung für sie findet
opel-manager 66
wir haben alles von der schweizer
behörden heisst das stimmt aber schritt
für schritt ich meine wir wollen ihn
sehen und es kommen für drei wochen
flüchtlinge nicht akzeptieren das sagen
die probleme kriegt so aber kommen her
und sagen dass ich weiß nie wie drei
wochen her und keine wohnung
das habe ich gehört hab ich habe gehört
er ich finde diese zentrum richtig also
gehört
ich war nicht das problem ist ich nie
gesagt ich darf mich sagen ich habe max
man nicht sagen konnte die probleme
diese personen weiß habe ich nicht
alleine sagen die leute sind nicht nicht
erreichen diese lebens da das nicht dass
cottbus schauen warum ist nicht rein
lasst ihn da darfst du krankenkassen du
hast war es das erste alles aber die
leute sagen ich es nicht gut warum was
wir bekommen hier uns die ganze welt ist
nicht gut ja heute essen und dann ist
eine plötzlich weg mehr dazu am nächsten
sonntag
[Musik]